[Music]
the earth will have a close encounter in
just a few minutes with a massive
asteroid nicknamed the rock
it's the largest asteroid to approach us
since 2004 NASA first learned about it
three years ago and the scientists say
it will pass earth by just over a
million miles the rock will not have any
effect on our planet but it does
highlight the dangers of nearby objects
CBS News science and futurists
contributor that's Michio Kaku is a
physics professor at the City University
of New York and joins us once again at
the table I know when you're here it's
good news as evidence when I said in the
green room how worried should we be what
does this mean you go well we're sitting
ducks I went okay yeah that's a good way
to start the morning right we're like
deer caught in the headlights this is a
whopper of an asteroid it's almost a
mile across that's a lot of real estate
and if it were to land in your backyard
you would really ruin your day but how
likely is that well we need an insurance
policy you know every ten years a
whopper of an asteroid comes barreling
right close to the earth missing us by a
whisker and we are blissfully unaware of
this now they don't hit us unless you
have to wait a few centuries or a few
millennia so we're a little too sleep
but I think we need an insurance policy
because one day it could really have our
name on what's an insurance policy well
first we need a telescope up there that
specifically identifies all these
near-earth asteroids of which we've
identified 14,000 and there could be a
million of them down to the size of a
football field
so first is a satellite that can take
pictures of these things and second we
have no Bruce Willis to come to the
rescue
there's no shuttle side though walking
around yeah they need to modify the SLS
booster rocket on Orion module so that
we can intercept one of these things is
we can't depend upon Hollywood to come
to the rescue every time one of these no
matter where he lives these things our
nation busters they could take out
England if it were to hit that's the
power of one of these asteroid 10,000
Hiroshima bombs is the power packed by
this piece of real estate am I
just one number when you say close how
many miles are we talking about we're
talking about four times the distance
between the earth to the moon but in 10
years timer so in 2029 another asteroid
will come by that'll go right through
our atmosphere think about the it'll go
Billy beneath our satellites that's how
close the Apophis asteroid will come in
2029 and again we're we're basically
helpless and what do you want people to
do with this information you say we're
helpless we're sitting ducks what do you
want us to do where we go to get a
telescope go give it to the telescope
for it you can get a telescope and on
the internet you can actually watch it
tonight on the Internet
second of all Congress gives us the
giggle factor every time I go to
Congress we got to convince Congress to
fund projects where we can deflect
asteroids like this I'll be calling you
a night if you're watching a story I'm
gonna go over to his house I was
thinking oh my hands professor what are
you doing to prepare the end of the
world